[Musica]
hai cercato di rispondere alla domanda
posta dalla biennale quest'anno dando
vita al tuo padiglione italia e questo
padiglione cerca di proporre mostrare
possibili scenari
opportunità per
dare una risposta a questo come sarà
questo futuro in una realtà che sta
cambiando tanto velocemente che ci sta
mettendo davanti a delle sfide piuttosto
arduo ed affrontare quindi dal tuo punto
di vista in quanto architetto
soprattutto ti chiedo qual è oggi ancora
prima dell'architettura il ruolo
dell'architetto in questa costruzione
e tanto bisogna
tenere presente che in un mondo appunto
il cambiamento così rapido
dobbiamo dare molta importanza dobbiamo
incominciare a riprendere in
considerazione il ruolo della creatività
in generale quindi diciamo che questo
caso prendiamo ad esempio il ruolo
dell'architetto come quello di un
creativo ma in questo momento storico
permette il ruolo del cattivo di andare
anche oltre la figura dell'architetto
quanto riguarda l'architetto certamente
la cosa più immediata da pensare che si
debba ritornare alla definizione
originaria quella che fu presa in
considerazione da risponderle per la
prima volta
sostanzialmente ritornare all'etimologia
della parola
arquitectonica e troppo spesso abbiamo
interpretato come capo costruttore in
realtà aristotele fa riferimento a un
costruttore di idee quindi una massima
espressione di
capacità creativa possibile una
costruzione di idee che quindi andava
anche ben oltre quella che noi chiamiamo
l'architettura degli edifici o delle
città ma se pensiamo alla pa
l'antropologia la creatività nasce molto
prima di aristotele forse addirittura
200.000 anni prima
l'esercizio della creatività e l'origine
stessa della nostra civiltà secondo la
pa l'antropologa e tra frigo
la paletnologia fatti ci insegna che
l'attività è una modalità di pensiero
una prerogativa dell'uomo che ha
consentito all'umanità stessa di
superare le crisi ambientali ed è una
modalità alternativa al pensiero che ne
e aree alla logica razionale che
che diciamo la modalità standard il
pensiero è l'uomo in questo senso in
biologia come in palio topologia
evidentemente non c'è una corrispondenza
tra la parola razionalità e funzionalità
come noi la intendiamo in architettura o
nella presentazione delle città nella
costruzione delle città infatti abbiamo
commesso proprio dolore di pensare che
funzionalità razionalità fossero la
stessa cosa abbiamo costruito quindi
città per scenari futuri che non
lasciavano spazio alla creatività e
creatività in questo caso city si
intende proprio l'imprevedibilità dei
fenomeni per esempio climatici quindi è
chiaro che alla mia mano così alla
creatività della natura che risponde in
modo complesso anche disordinato ci
vuole la stessa capacità creativa da
parte dell'umanità un po come diceva
einstein non si può non possiamo
utilizzare per risolvere dei problemi
quegli strumenti che i problemi li hanno
creati
quindi come diceva stephen jay gould
dovremmo fidarci un'importante biologo
alla palla più gravi grandi progetti che
conosciamo che la selezione naturale
su questo pianeta le selezioni naturale
attraverso l'ex a passion è la serie di
vita creativa ha superato il
determinismo e amos punto cos'è la vera
creatività
grazie alessandro un po l'hai già
anticipato tu è però mi piace molto
questo tuo concetto che spesso introduci
nei tuoi interventi di creatività come
un vero e proprio strumento di costruire
scenari più inclusivi più pronti al
cambiamento che è una di quelle
fondamentali aspetti ad oggi che rendono
una cosa più sostenibile e in questo
senso so che tu hai parlato anche tanto
di razionalità contrapposta alla
creatività quindi mi piacerebbe
capire un pochino più in dettaglio come
la creatività contribuisce a creare
questi scenari e cosa c'è invece della
razionalità che non ha forse più senso
ad oggi
quale sempre più semplice forse proprio
pensare alle città immaginiamoci che
l'architetto pianificatore ma tutti noi
abbiamo sempre pensato che per
risolvere i problemi del futuro dobbiamo
immaginarci uno scenario è che a quello
scenario dobbiamo far corrispondere del
funzione dei bisogni e questi bisogni a
questi bisogni facciamo corrispondere a
loro volta del delle forme
ora immaginiamo cv quello scenario non
si realizzi significa che quelle
funzioni non potranno essere assolte da
quelle forme in quel dato scenario
questo significa razionalismo cioè
significa che noi abbiamo pensato di
prevedere una condizione una serie di
cause di conseguenze e quindi di
determinare uno scenario che potesse
rispondere diciamo che potesse essere
studiato per dare una risposta alle
nostre esigenze
la realtà è molto più complessa di così
la natura è molto più complessa è la
natura stessa ci dà gli strumenti per
come dire per risolvere questo enigma è
lo risolve in modo molto semplice non
ipotizzando uno scenario futuro
determinato perché gli scenari possono
essere milioni ma ipotizzando delle
strutture che sono più
versatili possibile è che quindi si
possono adattare a qualsiasi condizione
futura queste strutture che sono poi il
cuore della definizione di exaptation
del biologo stephen jay gould sono
quindi le strutture che sono capaci di
essere intrinsecamente diverse variabili
ridondanti un po come il cervello umano
come il dna come quasi tutto quello che
esiste natura ad eccezione per esempio
purtroppo spesso delle nostre pure delle
nostre città quindi noi sappiamo
esattamente quali sono le
caratteristiche che determinano la
creatività
abbiamo parlato di questa funzionalità
irrazionale per funzionalità razionale
si intende la capacità di realizzare
delle forme delle strutture che siano
are sufficientemente diverse variabili
ridondanti per non rispondano a
rispondere a una funzione specifica va
di potersi adattare a condizioni che
sono del tutto inaspettate e
imprevedibile che vanno anche al di là
delle aspettative di chi le disegna
questa è fondamentalmente da chiave
della
creatività e non è una definizione come
dire filosofica è una definizione che
deriva in modo diretto dalla natura e
chiaro che questa definizione implica
che una presa di coscienza implica una
casa di conoscenza di una complessità di
uno scenario del mondo che va oltre
quella idea di dicotomie della realtà
che abbiamo costruito fino a oggi cioè
il vuoto il pieno l'ordine il disordine
la complessità è qualcosa che scardina
queste nostre esigenze di dividere il
mondo in
dicotomie in ragionamenti binari
quindi immaginiamoci che questioni come
l'ordine che sono state considerate fino
ad oggi essenziali diventano in realtà
dei problemi di vento dei problemi
perché l'ordine di per sé esclude il
disordine quindi esclude la complessità
in realtà quello che la biologia ci
insegna è che in architettura dovremmo a
prendere è che questa dimensione del
disordine che dovremmo abbracciare una
dimensione che va al di là delle forme
delle strutture ma coinvolge la società
quello che sto dicendo in parole più
semplici e che se vorremmo superare le
crisi nel futuro dovremo immaginarci o
meno gli scenari della città futura a
immaginarci delle società più giuste non
può esistere una
città del futuro sostenibile senza una
città più giusta ma non per ragioni
ideologiche ma semplicemente perché una
società più giusta e una società che ha
al suo interno un maggiore diversità
maggiore inclusività maggiore ridondanza
maggiore variabilità e quindi maggiore
creatività ed i più importanti avere
questa grande piattaforma culturale che
apre le porte a come dire forme
inaspettate idee della città inaspettate
che sono molto più importanti di quella
di aspettarsi un idea da me dire un
architetto della dieta occidentale
bianco maschio che è abituato a
realizzare le città in un certo modo e
di la diversità uno strumento essenziale
del
dl della creatività e la serie di vita
creativa è quella caratteristica che ci
consente quindi di superare il
determinismo nazionalista
grazie alessandro bellissima questa
suggestione di
inclusività come un bisogno biologico
prima ancora che ideologico penso che è
indecisi si possono affidare a questo
diciamo e ciò che hai detto che non ti
piace l'idea di avere scenari di città
futuri perché come come hai detto fino
adesso è difficile immaginare gli
scenari futuri e non ne abbiamo del
tutto gli strumenti però cercando di ri
attaccarci al tema di questo evento che
è nutrire il futuro feeding the feature
ti vorrei chiedere un ultima suggestione
su come vedi delle città resilienti
proattive del futuro e su quali
caratteristiche dovrebbero avere
ricevo anche una città della diversità
come dicevo prima quindi una città che
supera l'idea per esempio della
periferia del centro della della
marginalità come un problema anzi che
prende come dire sfrutta questa
potenzialità
possiamo immaginare appunto non uno
scenario futuro non processo ecco in
questa complessità niente direi che
proprio gli organismi che sono presenti
in natura sono quelli che ci consentono
di comprendere al meglio come possa
essere governata questa complessità
quindi proviamo a immaginarci
una città diversa da quella che abbiamo
oggi quindi non una città costruita in
modo tale che poi debba essere anche
motilità da noi dobbiamo immaginarci una
costa una città che che nutra noi e il
pianeta una città in sostanza che come
si sa si sa come una pianta che debba
essere e coltivata e come le piante e le
nutriamo perché loco la loro volta sono
in grado di nutrire noi e quindi
immaginiamoci un mondo in cui come nel
mondo naturale nel mondo del vegetale
moda animale esista una natura che senza
senza rifiuti senza
niente che non si possa riutilizzare
ecco questa è una città intrinsecamente
ecologica ed è una città anche che
attive che ci consentirebbe di superare
le emergenze cristiano attraversato 12
grazie alessandro con questo concludiamo
e richiamo sul palco giordano grazie